cancer is the second leading cause of
death accounting for nearly 21.7 percent
of all deaths per year in the United
States with cancer being so frequent and
deadly you'd want the most effective
treatments if you ever got diagnosed
ultimately survival comes down to the
type of cancer and the degree of its
aggressiveness surgery and radiation are
very effective tools as they do cause
the least harm to the patient and have
good success rates but surgery and
radiation only work in specific
situations like if the tumor is found
early and hasn't spread but what if the
cancer metastasizes you can't surgically
remove mobile cancer cells and radiation
can't pinpoint every new potential
growth this is where chemotherapy comes
in chemotherapy isn't an actual drug but
an umbrella term for drugs that target
cancer like cells the chemo drugs are
injected into the patient's bloodstream
and circulate throughout the body in
hopes that it comes in contact with
tumors growth in muscles and organs but
how do chemotherapy drugs actually kill
cancer cells simple they target the
cell's DNA if the cell's DNA is damaged
or the replication process that copies
DNA is damaged the cell will die this is
because cells have a natural safety
mechanism that causes it to undergo a
puto --ss or cell suicide when DNA is
negatively affected this is to prevent
mutated or damaged DNA from replicating
in proliferating a bad cell line
so basically chemo breaks the DNA and
the cell commits suicide to stop the DNA
from making more broken DNA chemotherapy
drugs affect DNA in two ways either by
directly attacking the DNA itself or
indirectly by inhibiting enzymes that
replicate the DNA for example some
chemotherapy drugs attack DNA itself by
cross-linking neighboring nucleotides to
each other preventing it from being
replicated properly cell mechanisms see
that the DNA can't replicate and it
initiates cell suicide other chemo drugs
will inhibit an enzyme called
topoisomerase which unwinds strands of
DNA so it can be properly replicated
with this enzyme halted replication can
complete and the cell activates its
suicide mechanism a more widely used
class of chemo drugs are called mitotic
inhibitors these drugs attacks
cells that are a particular phase of
their cell cycle in this case the cells
are in mitosis mitosis prepares the cell
to undergo cell division into two new
cells once in mitosis the mitotic
inhibitors block enzymes that complete
the cycle locking the cell in mitosis
causing it to activate a Patou --ss
these drugs are very useful in targeting
cancer cells because cancer cells have
abnormally high rates of growth and are
therefore more likely to be in mitosis
than a regular slower growing cell
cancers like leukemia which are
particularly aggressive and growth are
heavily targeted by mitotic inhibitors
unfortunately cancer cells aren't the
only fast-growing cells in the body
epithelial cells in the intestine skin
cells and cells involved in hair growth
have very high growth rates and are
targeted by mitotic inhibitors this
explains why cancer patients lose their
hair get skin rashes and have bouts of
vomiting from excessive cell death now
you may think that mitotic inhibitors
are a cure-all for cancer it's far from
that one reason is that not all cancers
grow fast this is a setback for mitotic
inhibitor drugs because if the cells
grow slow that means the cell will less
likely be in mitosis and therefore are
resistant to mitotic inhibitors making
these treatments more harmful than good
this is why cancer is often dealt with a
multi treatment approach you'd be crazy
to solely rely on chemo or surgery alone
often multiple methods are used for
example once the tumor is found and
removed its location is then radiate
additionally chemotherapy may also be
used in case of potential metastasis
[Music]